I just moved, and this is the hottest fucking summer I can think of.
And still, the clothes that I made sure that I could find
and that I could wear in this heat,
in this move was my halara.
This jumpsuit is amazing. Material is so fucking lightweight.
You can handle in the summer.
It fits so nicely, you don't fucking get hot.
It's like, I'm not kidding you.
I don't wanna feel like shit.
I'm, like,
hot and sweaty, but I don't wanna feel like shit,
and I don't wanna be overly hot,
so this is perfect. The wide legs,
I'm. Feels like I'm still wearing shorts.
The fabric is really light.
It's got pockets. And then when I look at myself,
I'm like, oh, wait.
But I don't look like shit.
Maybe I feel like shit on the inside,
and maybe I could, you know,
fix up the other parts.
But overall, I swear to god,
this Halara jumpsuit, that does come in plus sizes,
so anyone can wear it. Totally summer.
Shittiest situation of life.
Moving,
still I choose my whole arm jumpsuit.